the page is starting to look more like
the design but we're still missing the
image to use the image you have to store
it somewhere where the page can access
it make a folder called images inside
your project folder and put the image
there make sure the image name does not
contain any spaces or accented
characters or else it will make linking
to it more difficult you can add the
image to the page with the tag IMG and
providing the source of the image like
so you should also always provide this
alt attribute which displays alternate
information to the screen in case the
browser cannot display the image once
you have added the image the page look a
lot more like the actual design mock but
how does our page still differ from the
design mock is the header background and
text color still different are the
margins and padding for the boxes still
different what about the borders of the
boxes what about the font size and style
do we still need to update those